I think you're gonna like this one too
Republican congressman who claimed that
they inadvertently hung out with a
Holocaust denier have I guess
accidentally hung out with him again I'm
talking about dana rohrabacher who's
also known to us as congressman russia
also Matt Gaetz who's another massive
trump supporter both previously hung out
with far-right Holocaust denier and sort
of provocateur Chuck C Johnson and
Johnson if you're not familiar with him
I understand I I imagine he's not a
prominent figure among most of our
audience he spent years promoting fake
news on his got news website he was
banned for life from Twitter for trying
to raise money to quote take out black
lives matter activists and last year he
started saying things like he doesn't
believe the six million figure meaning
that six million Jews were killed in the
Holocaust that the real number is
probably more like two hundred and fifty
thousand and mostly from typhus not from
gas chambers and work camps
concentration camps and death camps
which he indicated he doesn't believe
are actually real and what what they
called the entire thing gates and were
Ibaka when they were questioned about
the fact that they were hanging out with
a Holocaust denier they said no no no
it's all it's all just a
misunderstanding on as far as gates is
concerned Gates said well I got a ticket
to Chuck C Johnson to go to trump State
of the Union as my guest but it wasn't
really because I wanted to bring them
specifically he just sort of showed up
at my office and it was so confusing and
I ended up giving the guy a ticket but
then later on Fox News gates denied that
Chuck C Johnson is a white supremacist
or a Holocaust denier so that's gates
then you have Dana Rohrabacher who let
Johnson for some reason that escapes me
sit in during a meeting that Rohrabacher
had with Senator Rand Paul and there's
no reasonable explanation for that one
either
Rohrabacher said something like he
didn't invite Johnson to the meeting so
I guess Johnson somehow got into a
meeting between two members of Congress
without an invitation how that happened
isn't clear but then once he was there
nobody thought to ask him to leave
either so it's really weird but they
chalked it up just to misunderstandings
but now they know who he is and it's not
going to happen again but we've now
learned that they were with him again
over the summer Johnson was on a yacht
fundraiser in Newport Beach California
on behalf of Matt Gaetz his re-election
campaign at which Dana Rohrabacher gave
a speech and the entire event was hosted
by two guys one of whom the holocaust
denying Johnson previously called a
mentor it was just another confusing
accident it was crazy nobody knew what
was going on and and before they knew it
there was the same Holocaust denier
again how on earth did that happen these
Republican extremists hanging out with
Holocaust deniers is not actually that
newsworthy to me there's been this
commingling of extreme republicanism
Holocaust denial and virulent
anti-semitism for a long time I think
the more interesting part is that
decades ago the survivors of the call of
Holocaust said that this was going to
happen they said we need to take every
opportunity to memorialize what happened
because with time deniers are going to
start to crop up they're going to cast
doubt upon that what that that which we
now know happened and the more time that
goes by after the Holocaust the more
that they are going to be listened to
this is why such an effort has been made
all over the world in so many countries
and countries involved with the
perpetrating of the Holocaust and also
in countries that were victimized by the
Holocaust they have memorials they have
museums they have exhibits it's to
prevent exactly this type of historical
revisionism not only from happening but
from achieving a foothold and if you
want to see how prevalent it is look up
articles about this story this story
involving Dana
Bakker and Matt Gaetz and Chuck C
Johnson and read the comments and you
will see how prominent Holocaust denial
is whenever people say well do we really
need to keep talking about the Holocaust
yes we do because they keep talking
about it and saying things like only
250,000 people died and of typhus and
Hitler wasn't actually that bad so
clearly we do need to keep talking about
it